if he is building a tree tower which is
a tower built on top of a tree the tree
is currently five meters tall and if he
has found it out if he or I fee and if
he has found it is growing by 0.1 meters
a month or a tenth of a meter month the
tower is currently 2 meters tall
so this tower that sits on top of the
tree is 2 meters tall currently and if
he or I fee adds to it at about zero
point 2 meters a month so I guess he or
she I don't know if he won't let's just
say he is built is continuously building
this tower on this continuously growing
tree which is fascinating
all right the function a of M returns
the trees height in meters and months
from now
fascinating the function B of M returns
the towers height in meters and months
from now so this is the tree side a of M
is a tree sight B of M is the towers
height find the formula of the two
functions so a of M so they tell us the
tree is currently 5 meters tall so it's
going to be 5 meters tall right at the
start and then every month it is growing
by 0.1 meters so it's going to be 5 plus
0.1 times M and this M here this is not
meters this is actually the months
remember M returns M is the number of
months so after 0 months which is right
now where this is just going to be five
after one month it's going to be five
point one after two months it's going to
be five point two which is exactly what
we want all right now let's think about
the tower so the formula for B of M so
the tower is currently 2 meters tall so
it's currently 2 meters tall and it
grows at two-tenths of a meter per month
so two-tenths times the number of months
and once again this M right over here is
not meters I'm not writing the unit's
here we're just assuming that whatever
this returns is in meters this M right
over here is the number of months that
pass by the number of months from now
all right the function C of M returns
the vertical distance between the ground
and the top end of the tower it makes
sense that would be from the bottom of
the tree to the top of the tower right
the formula C of M in terms of a and a
of M and B of n well the total height is
going to be the height of the tree which
is a of M plus the height of the tower
plus V of M plus B of n that's what C of
M is going to be and then they say write
the formula of C of M in terms of M well
we just need to add these two functions
if we add five plus 0.1 m 2 2 plus 0.2 m
that's going to be so we could add 5
plus 2 and we're going to get 7 plus and
if I have 0.1 m and I add another point
to M that's going to be 0.3 m 0 0.3 m
and we are done we got it right